boris cyrulnik auteurs le laboureur et
les mangeurs de vin c'est votre dernier
ouvrage merci d'être avec nous nuire aux
psychiatres philosophe écrivain vous
allez bien
ça va bien se bat encore bon ben tant
mieux la dernière fois qu'on s'est parlé
mais se sert uniquement les gens me
parlent encore de cette entrevue c'était
la stupeur du début de la pandémie
sur la résilience sur les leçons qu'on
devrait tirer de tout ça vous en est ou
presque deux ans et quelques plus tard
est ce qu'avec le recul finalement pilon
avec la guerre en ukraine on mesure que
dans trois quatre ans on aura peut-être
oublié tout simple
non je pense part je fais le pari que on
est un virage social nouveau contrat
social et il va falloir réorganiser à la
sortie du virus qui est en train de se
sécher maintenant il va falloir
réorganiser repenser notre manière de
vivre ensemble parce que si on fait
aussi on remet en place les mêmes
processus on va rentrer dans le siècle
des verrues ce que je pense et la guerre
en ukraine ne fait qu' aggraver ce qui
s'est passé ces deux dernières années
donc vous n'êtes qu'un on devra on
devrait même tirer des leçons mais est
ce que c'est ce que vous constatez
autour de vous alors que la normalité
reprend ses droits
alors ce que je constate c'est qu'il ya
une petite partie de la population qui
veut recommencer comme avant mais par
bonheur il ya des tas de gens qui sont
prêts à changer l'école l'université
la manière de consommer la manière de se
déplacer un nouveau contrat social et
que on est déjà en plein chantier pour
faire évoluer comme ça se passe à
d'ailleurs après chaque catastrophe que
ce soit une catastrophe naturelles
tremblements de terre ou une catastrophe
culturelle la guerre où le virus les
deux sont une catastrophe culturelle on
constate pratiquement toujours qu' il y
ait un changement de culture une
nouvelle renaissance
d'accord mais encore une fois c'est un
souhait que vous exprimez que plusieurs
exprime mais il ya quand même cette
crainte qu'on va recommencer à voyager
comme avant on va recommencer à
surconsommer comme avant qu'on va
recommencer
malheureusement à vivre pas mal comme
avant
oui parce que là il y aura dans deux ans
un nouveau virus et il faudra
recommencer vacciner se confiner
s'opposer aux antilles au axe et sert à
boris cyrulnik votre dernier livre est
fort intéressant de savoir m'amener
après la guerre en ukraine mais d'abord
dans ce livre vous dites le laboureur et
les mangeurs de vent qu'il est beaucoup
plus difficile
de penser par soi même de penser
librement qu'il est plus facile par
attachement au groupe de se fondre dans
la grande majorité et que donc de suivre
parfois des despotes des dictateurs des
gourous et que se libérer de ça ce n'est
pas évident
non parce que se soumettre
à la voix de la majorité
c'est la pensée paresseuse totti donne
en effet de grands avantages c'est la
confortable servitude on n'a que des
amis on sourit on récite on n'a pas
besoin de faire l'effort de pensée pour
récit de quelques slogans c'est très
euphorisant mais la pensée complètement
arrêtées et dans un contexte pareil
quand la doxa le l'opinion convenu
devient un courant principal celui celle
qui réfléchit par elle-même se
retrouvent en situation de solitude et
c'est souvent très difficile
c'est ce qui est arrivé à hannah arendt
quand elle a voulu penser par elle-même
après le procès eichmann elle a perdu
tous ses amis et vous raconter dans ce
livre vous revenez à votre enfance boris
cyrulnik en janvier 44 vos parents ont
été déportés déjà mourront vous êtes
protégé une partie de la guerre mais
finalement il ya une rafle à bordeaux
vous est envoyé à la synagogue dans
cette rafle et la cisa
vous avez devant vous la mort et ça ça a
été fondateur pour vous
oui mais ses fondateurs pour tous les
enfants c'est à dire que les premières
années de la vie donne une vision du
monde et c'est pour ça que chaque vision
du monde est en fait un aveu
autobiographique on a chacun notre
manière de voir le monde et cette
manière là a été sculptée imprégné en
nous dans notre cerveau au cours des
premières années de la vie ça thématise
toute notre existence
et vous aviez besoin vous êtes vous
expliquez bien dans votre lit vous aviez
besoin
de rationaliser vous n'aviez pas besoin
qu'on vous répète maintenant mais oublie
ça s'est terminé 2e en sécurité vous
avez besoin de comprendre comment
d'autres hommes avaient pu vous menacer
de mort parce que j'avais échappé
évidemment la mort mais vous auriez pu
mourir j'aurais pu aussi être déportés
et vous avez besoin de comprendre ça
d'où cette idée que tous les allemands
étaient pas des [ __ ] que tous les
cambodgiens sous paul pattes étaient pas
des [ __ ] non plus et c'est ça que
vous développez finalement
exactement c'est à dire que la pensée
paresseuse c'est de dire les allemands
sont des barbares ce qu'on entend encore
et c'est faux c'est totalement faux
l'allemagne était le pays le plus
cultivé d'occident il nous a fait
bénéficier de musiciens de philosophes
de mathématiciens de scientifiques
magnifique mais il y avait un clivage
dans la société allemande entre un top
très cultivé dont on a tous bénéficié et
une base largué et la confortable
servitude a consisté à se soumettre à la
jeunesse hitlérienne qui est apparu qui
a été fondée dès 1924 et j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de genres et discuter je même
une amie qui a été élevé dans les
jeunesses hitlériennes et ses témoins me
raconte le bonheur de se soumettre à une
théorie nazis absurde stupide et qui a
convaincu des millions de gens sur la
planète et qui a provoqué une tragédie
non seulement pour les juifs mais pour
la planète entière il ya eu 50 millions
de morts avait des origines et les
canadiens ont payé très cher le cette
tragédie quand ils ont cherché quand ils
ont débarqué en normandie ils ont payé
tout le monde a été embarqué à cette
tragédie alors que si vous prenez le
temps de lire quelques pages de mein
kampf j'ai pas tout lu mais lisez
quelque part c'est incroyable qu'on ait
pu croire des âneries pareilles
confortable servitude bon et justement
vous et vous remonter à l'enfance c'est
ça qui est intéressant vous dites il ya
des gens mieux armé que d'autres pour
sortir de ce groupe pour ne pas avoir
peur du rejet
du de ce besoin absolu d'appartenance au
groupe et il ya quand même des gens qui
ont la force de sortir de ça
alors je sais qu'une force affective
lorsqu'on fait des études
populationnelles sur les enfants on
constate que la dès l'âge de 10 mois
certains enfants aux acquis une petite
estime de soi il aime les relations ils
n'ont pas peur de l'autre ils font un
mobile il commence à peine à marcher ils
savent pas parler et pourtant ils font
ils tirent sur la manche ils font un
sourire ils établissent une relation et
ces enfants là sont ceux qui ont acquis
l'attachement fait qu on a gardé
l'anglicisme parce qu'on avait besoin de
2 mo - début je suis sécurisé si ma mère
est là mais je suis secure si je reste
sécurisé quand ma mère n'est pas là donc
ces deux concepts un peu différent donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a gardé l'anglicisme
je crois que le mot secure eux et
maintenant à vaty la nationalité
française parce que maintenant dans les
publications je le vois écrit avec un
accent et c'est pour sabrer ses rues
n'est que vous êtes ici important
l'enfance parce que ça fait si justement
l'attachement est bien fait pile la
sécurité etc
ça fait des citoyens plus les bras
c'est ça exactement ça fait les citoyens
qui éprouvent le plaisir de choisir si
j'ai un choix j'ai donc un degré de
liberté mais pour avoir un choix il faut
je rencontre une théorie une personne et
que je rencontre une autre théorie qui
me dire autre chose une autre personne
et qu'ensuite je décide dont j'ai acquis
un degré de liberté mais c'est ça c'est
le classe seulement de 70% des
populations des pays en paix parce que
quand les observations sont faits dans
des pays en guerre
c'est 30 et 40% selon l'intensité de la
guerre c'est à dire qu'on perd sa
liberté
parlant de guerre comment vous comment
vous réagissez quand vous entendez des
gens dirhams et puccini fou les russes
ne savent pas ce qu'ils font
c'est plus complexe que ça encore une
fois si on applique ce que vous décrivez
les russes sont baignés dans un discours
dans un art actifs qui c'est plus
sécurisant de rester dans ce narratif
light donc estimé qu'il est juste de
battre n'est ce pas contre les
ukrainiens
voilà les rues sont baignés dans un
article il paraît que 80 % des russes
accepte le récit inventé par poutine
parce que c'est confortable pour eux ça
déclenche le bonheur de la solidarité et
le bonheur aussi devant la conviction
d'avoir raison et c'est ce qui c'est
mais
l'explication par la folie d'un homme
par poutine ne me paraît pas du tout
acceptable quand j'étais enfant après la
guerre on expliquer la seconde guerre
mondiale par la syphilis ou par la
paranoïa de hitler et quand je me
demandais comment la syphilis d'un homme
pouvait expliquer un phénomène mondial
quand je voyais que par exemple une
jeune femme agrégatifs qui s'appelait
hélène berr elles trois elles pas son
agrégation d'anglais à la sorbonne à
paris pour sorel sur eux pour se
détendre et se réfugie dans le petit
square le jardin public qui est devant
elle la voisin un téléphone la police
l'art est elle va à drancy elle va au
fils et elle meurt elle avait 22 ans son
crime s'était de s'être assis dans un
jardin public mais elle avait l'étoile
de david
c'est à dire qu'on a là un délit
logique sociale et non pas celui d'un
homme je vois pas la syphilis de hitler
ne peut pas expliquer ce que je viens de
vous proposer il faut que vraiment tout
le monde se soit soumis à un délire
logique c'est à dire logique c'est à
dire non psychotique et pourtant
délirant et ce délire social vous et il
est très difficile de faire en sorte que
les russes pour reprendre l'exemple la
russie vis-à-vis poutine se sortent de
sa individuellement uns après les autres
c'est tellement confortable qu'il ya des
raisons psychanalytiques la psyché
tellement confortable d'être avec le
groupe qu'on est presque pris alors il
est où l'espoir aurait cyrulnik en
terminant mais oui c'est très difficile
de rester
indépendant et de ne pas se soumettre au
courant des idées parce qu'il ya les
contagions décidé c'est très l'école est
croyante sont très contagieuses
tellement les apportent de bénéfices
immédiats mais j'étais enfant après la
libération et j'étais près de bordeaux
j'ai vu une bataille à bataillon
allemand encerclé par les résistants pas
par l'armée française et ils se sont
rendu aux résistants et j'ai vu ces
hommes qui étaient des surhommes en
entrant dans castillon où j'étais
quelques jours après c'est sûr hommes
étaient devenus des hommes gentils et
qui nous tendaient des fruits qui
cherchent à nous parler et quand on veut
en parler avec une musique tous on a
dégrisé années quand j'ai parlé avec des
gens qui ont été dans les jeunesses
hitlériennes
c'est seulement des années après la
guerre qu'ils ont pris conscience de ce
qui est de la théorie qu'il avait
accepté et à ce moment là il ya eu des
déchirures très grave dans la prise de
conscience a été douloureuse mais c'est
après une prise de conscience alors
qu'on est dallas la masse qui se dirige
vers même un point aux règles c'est très
difficile de de se sortir de sa routine
l'essai après voilà alors non en france
après la guerre on a eu une période
bénie occire parce que le déni aussi
était confortable ne pas prendre
conscience de la réalité ça permettait
aux français d'éviter de prendre
conscience que l'armée française et est
partie en courant devant l'armée
allemande et surtout d'éviter que le
gouvernement de vichy avait devancé les
ordres des nazis donc c'était une chose
difficile à accepter donc le déni était
un facteur de protection béquille
empêché d'affronter la réalité aurait
serré unique très concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire avec les enfants
pour qu'ils aient plus de facilité
adultes à être libre davantage libre
alors merci pour votre question parce
qu'on est en train de travailler sur sa
selle sur votre question c'est à dire
que c'est l'éducation
l'université et la culture qui peuvent
répondre à votre question au lieu
d'apprendre à nos enfants de les inviter
à réciter pour être reçus à leur examen
alors en france on dit bachoter on dit
ça aussi au québec bachelot ténors mais
en compassion désert de
régurgiter enfin bref -
régurgiter pour être reçus il faut leur
apprendre comme dans les pays d'europe
du nord aujourd'hui il faut leur
apprendre à réfléchir et donc à choisir
et à décider et l'université de hand
maintenant elle devra apprendre aussi à
développer le phénomène des races lui ce
qui existe en europe et qui consiste à
avoir des années sabbatiques après le
baccalauréat pour visiter une autre
culture une autre religion un autre
continent et une autre langue et les
jeunes qui font une année sabbatique
quand ils reviennent chez eux n'ont pas
pratiquement pas d'échec scolaire alors
qu'en france ce qui cinq cents gars
jouent tout de suite après le bac 11 50
à 60 % d'échec scolaire
très intéressant qui voudraient tous il
faut parce qu on obéit à sa mère en
obéit à l'école vous êtes en obéir mais
il faut apprendre à désobéir aussi
alors on peut pas le bénéfice de
l'obéissance est très grand si on n'a
pas de mère à laquelle obéir on a une
espérance de vie qui est très brève donc
l'emploi l'emprise maternelle
l'obéissance et un mode socialisation
mais au cours de notre développement on
apprend petit à petit l'âge du nom
c'est à dire où on a tous connu ça tous
les parents ont connu ça on est en
retard vient vite habille toi et hop
l'enfant part se cacher sous une table
ou nasa placard alors pour l'enfant
c'est une victoire intellectuelle jeu
devient autonome dont les parents pour
la mère si tu veux le faire rater mon
train donc c'est pas il ya des contres
déjà des controverses entre générations
et l'adolescence est un moyen moment une
période sensible d'une période critique
où on doit devenir autonome sans
s'opposer à nos parents il est on doit
pourtant donnons pas se détacher mais à
prendre un autre mode d'attachement
essai c'est la tête dure c'est la nature
le cinéma les rencontres les voyages
qu'ils peuvent apprendre ce changement
murray s'est réuni que vous dites puis
on va se laisser là dessus mais yann
phrase un vote clé vous êtes une enfance
raté peut être réparé
il n'y a pas d'absolu non plus
absolument c'est la seule chose c'est
que ce qui était absolue c'est que ça
peut être réparé absolument réparer et
pour ça on sait ce qu'il faut faire il
faut sécuriser la mère si l'enfant est
très petit pré verbale dans le vent la
troisième année il suffit il faut
sécuriser la mer dès que la mer est
sécurisé elle devient sécurisante pour
l'enfant et en dehors aux sciences ont
une photographie et aux doses que en
24-48 heures l'enfant recommence une
construction sereine donc la première
chose à faire c'est d'agir sur le milieu
qui agit sur l'enfant on sait ce qu'il
faut faire c'est très efficace puisque
on voit que par exemple en roumanie dès
que les enfants après le crime de
chevaucher sco qui a isolé 176000
enfants cent mille ont été récupérés
parce qu'une autre niche affective une
autre niche sensorielle a été organisée
autour de ces enfants 76 milles ne sont
pas récupérés parce qu'on les a isolés
trop précocément trop intensément et
trop longtemps il ya eu le même
phénomène pour les orphelins de
duplessis à montréal le même phénomène
certains ont été récupérés parce qu'ils
ont été entourées je pense notamment à
bruno roy mais votre promo nîmes qui est
devenu pour d'université parce que lui a
été entouré et d'autres n'ont pas pu
reprendre un bon développement résilient
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été entouré
reisser unique merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé on aurait pu continuer comme
ça très longtemps votre livre qui arrive
au québec la semaine prochaine laboureur
et les mangeurs de 20 c'est fort
intéressant vraiment on y réfléchit à
peu près à toutes les pages merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé encore une
fois merci m'avoir invité au québec